mitch mcconnell the senate majority
leader who released an ad yesterday
pointing out
why it is that democrats really should
not be allowed to
lead the country forward this is one of
the best ads of the campaign put out by
the senate majority pac
here is what it sounded like late nights
the early mornings the door knocking the
phone back
we put in the work we have the team
and the stakes couldn't be hired you're
considered the most
liberal united states senator
hi everything is on the line
now there's only one thing left to do
hold the line go vote that really is
going to be the republican line here is
that the threat of democrats is so bad
that they cannot be
let in charge of power and when you
watch what's happening in philadelphia
which is being basically
blacked out by the media i mean i'm
looking at the front pages
of various major publications and
there's very very little coverage of
what's happening in philadelphia so
overnight there were these massive riots
in philadelphia 1 000 people
looted the local walmart why because the
cops shot a black man who was charging
at them with a knife he had a knife they
told him to put it down
he was then 10 feet they tried to back
away he refused to listen to their
orders they shot him this is now created
two straight nights of brutal rioting
across philadelphia
and those riots resulted in some pretty
shocking footage okay the
and listen to the headlines from the
media i mean this is this is how you
know
that the democrats are scared about
pennsylvania because they refuse to
cover this stuff they just refuse
here is how cnn headlined this protest
erupts for a second night after a black
man fatally shot by philadelphia police
missing a little bit of context as we
would say in the fact-checking business
aren't you it wasn't just that a black
man was shot by the police it was that a
black man was holding a knife
and they told him put down the knife
repeatedly and he approached them
repeatedly and then they shot him
but apparently that no longer matters
i love listen the top headline at cnn
right now
philadelphia sees more protests over
fatal police shooting here's what one of
those protests looked like
in philadelphia last night this doesn't
look like a protest this looks like a
full-scale riot with people looting
stealing a pair of shoes to uh to
protest systemic american racism because
nothing says systemic american racism
quite like the cops allowing people
to uh loot the walmart does this look
like a protest to you
right here what you're watching doesn't
look like a protest to me the prior
night 30 police officers were injured
including a 56 year old female police
officer who was hit with a truck
broke her leg you can see cars are
literally pulling up to the walmart
people are getting out of the cars
they're running into the walmart and
they are just absconding with tvs
and and this is what democrats are
presiding over democrats are okay with
this
and they make noises about how they're
not super fond of it what exactly are
they doing to stop it
the mayor of philadelphia who's a
democrat said there were serious
questions to be asked about the incident
there were not
the police chief who's a democrat said
the same thing
okay this is the world that democrats
are apparently okay with because america
is systemically and institutionally
racist
thousands of people looting local stores
why would you ever invest in a business
in philadelphia again watching this
happen seriously well at least the
protesters the protesters here
some of them look like they're wearing
masks that's that's really the important
thing i noticed
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content